PRESIDENT ACTED IN UNPRECEDENTED
WAYS AND LITERALLY WITHIN THREE
WEEKS.
NOW, WE DO HAVE SOME BREAKING
NEWS MOMENTS AGO.
ACTOR TOM HANKS, HIS WIFE, RITA
WILSON, THEY HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS.
BY THE WAY, THEY ARE IN OUR
PRAYERS TONIGHT.
TRACE GALLAGHER, HE’S IN THE
WEST COAST NEWSROOM WITH THE
LATEST.
>> FOUND OUT ABOUT TWO OR THREE
MINUTES AGO, WHAT’S HAPPENING
HERE IS TOM HANKS AND RITA
WILSON WERE DOWN IN AUSTRALIA.
THEY ARE FILMING A NEW MOVIE
ABOUT ELVIS PRESLEY, AND TOM
HANKS IS PLAYING THE PART OF THE
FAMOUS COLONEL WHO TOOK CARE OF
ELVIS FOR MANY YEARS, AND WE
WERE KIND OF WORKING THIS STORY
EARLIER, NOW TOM HANKS HAS JUST
TWEETED, JUST MOMENTS AGO,
QUOTING HERE, HE SAYS, HELLO,
FOLKS, TREAT AND I ARE DOWN HERE
IN AUSTRALIA.
WE FELT A BIT TIRED.
LIKE WE HAD COLDS AND SOME BODY
ACHES.
RITA HAD SOME CHILLS THAT CAME
AND WENT, SLIGHT FEVERS, TOO.
TO PLAY THINGS RIGHT, AS IS
NEEDED IN THE WORLD RIGHT NOW,
WE WERE TESTED FOR CORONAVIRUS,
AND WERE FOUND TO BE POSITIVE.
THE QUESTION NOW IS, WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM DOWN THERE?
WELL, THE ANSWER APPEARS TO BE
FOR MEDICAL OFFICIALS, THEY WILL
HAVE TO FOLLOW ALL THE PROTOCOLS
MEANING THEY WILL BE TESTED,
OBSERVED AND ISOLATED FOR AS
LONG AS THE AUSTRALIAN PUBLIC
OFFICIALS WANT THEM TO BE.
IT’S UNCLEAR IF THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO ACTUALLY WORK DOWN
THERE AND WHAT THE PROCESS, AND
THE DAYS THAT THEY WILL ACTUALLY
BE UNDER ISOLATION OR
QUARANTINED IN AUSTRALIA, AND
WHAT THIS MEANS.
AS FAR AS THEIR HEALTH, SEAN,
AND HOW THEY ARE RIGHT NOW,
THAT’S ALSO UNCLEAR.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE TWEET AND
FROM THE TONE AND TENOR OF IT,
IT APPEARS THAT THEY ARE UPBEAT
AND WE’RE STILL LOOKING FOR MORE
INFORMATION ON THIS.
I JUST WANT TO CONTINUE WITH THE
BREAKING NEWS, NBA IS NOW
SUSPENDING THE SEASON BECAUSE OF
CORONAVIRUS, FOLLOWING TONIGHT’S
GAME, AND THIS COMES, AND I’M
QUOTING, NBA ANNOUNCED THAT A
PLAYER ON THE UTAH JAZZ HAS
PRELIMINARY TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVID-19, CORONAVIRUS.
THE TEST RESULT WAS REPORTED
SHORTLY PRIOR TO THE TIP-OFF OF
TONIGHT’S GAME BETWEEN THE JAZZ
AND OKLAHOMA CITY.
WE HAD HEARD EARLIER THAT THE
OKLAHOMA CITY GAME WAS CANCELED,
AND THE NBA WOULDN’T GIVE US ANY
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY IT WAS
CANCELED.
THEY JUST CUT THE GAME OFF.
WELL, NOW WE KNOW THAT ONE OF
THE JAZZ PLAYERS HAS
PRELIMINARILY TESTED POSITIVE
FOR COVID-19.
IT GOES ON TO SAY THE JAZZ AND
OKLAHOMA CITY THUNDER AT
CHESAPEAKE ENERGY ARENA AT THAT
TIME, TONIGHT’S GAME WAS
CANCELED.
THE AFFECTED PLAYER WAS NOT IN
THE ARENA AT THE TIME.
THE NBA IS SUSPENDING GAME PLAY
FOLLOWING THE CONCLUSION OF
TONIGHT’S SCHEDULE OF GAMES
UNTIL FURTHER NOTICE.
SO IT’S UNCLEAR IF THEY ARE
CANCELLING THE SEASON OR UNTIL
FURTHER NOTICE.
THE NBA HAS ABOUT 12, 13, 14
GAMES LEFT IN THE SEASON.
THE PLAYOFFS COULD BE LENGTHY.
IT GOES ALL THE WAY UNTIL JUNE,
LATE JUNE, MID-JUNE, SO WE’RE
TALKING ABOUT SEVERAL MONTHS.
THE QUESTION NOW BECOMES, IS THE
REST OF THE SEASON CANCELED?
ARE THEY JUST GOING TO TAKE A
BREAK FOR TWO WEEKS, OR, WE JUST
DON’T KNOW THE ANSWERS TO THAT